[Applause]
[Music]
military coming home to their families
what we don't see are the challenges
they face as they transition back to
normal life in our new series coming
home we follow the lives of our nation's
bravest as they return for more over
15,000 American servicemembers are
stationed in Afghanistan more than 16
years after the u.s. involvement there
began of the 2.7 million men and women
who served in Iraq and Afghanistan more
than half were deployed at least twice
Jan Crawford spoke with three Marines
who recently returned home Jan good
morning good morning you know less than
10% of Americans have served in the
military
this conflict may have faded from a lot
of people's memories so we talked with
three Marines about their experiences
and what it's like when they come back
home the images never get old the joy
love and relief of coming home for the
Marines of Task Force Southwest the
sacrifices to get to this moment started
almost a year ago when they arrived in
Helmand province
captain Tamara Watkins in majors Paul
Rivera and Ethan kromm now were part of
the first Marine unit to set foot in the
region since combat operations ended
there in 2014 with 13 overseas
deployments between them these three are
from very different backgrounds a Texas
transplant with more than 20 years
experience a Wisconsin family man who's
flown missions in both Iraq and
Afghanistan and a logistics officer who
joined ROTC during college in Florida
part of the roughly 8% of the Corps
that's female all three have felt a
similar call to serve always wanted to
be in the military joined the reserves
after high school started with the
childhood dream the purpose of their
most recent mission and one of the
country's bloodiest regions was to help
Afghan forces regain the upper hand over
the Taliban somebody says why are we
still in Afghanistan what do you say in
simplest terms because they need our
help and we have the capacity to do it
and after nine months it was time to go
home a day's long journey to camp
lejeune
anxious families were waiting our
cameras followed the meticulous process
of therefore our reentry overseen by
Watkins then an hour-long bus ride full
of anticipation challenging sometimes we
had our break down low in so every once
in a while of course we handled and
finally the moment I saw them as the bus
pulled up they were standing there they
made a sign and stuff like that our son
he couldn't get over but the sound of my
voice said why does your voice sound
like that so that's what it always
sounds like buddy when you're that small
nine months is you know like almost a
quarter of his life what is the hardest
thing to miss that these past nine
months the hugs that's someone I didn't
really remember missing that feeling
that feeling it you know you can
actually touch him now but before they
could settle in the Marines must first
brief their superiors in Washington
here's what we did here's what we saw
there's some value added to hear it
straight from the source we sat down
with them inside the Pentagon rather
mission was still fresh I think you just
have to look at the big picture as a
whole what we do on the small level
affects everything that is much larger
their service has met missing milestones
of their lives in 2010 Crum now was
stationed overseas when his wife gave
birth to their first baby girl she was
seven months pregnant when I left so
that was rough
like you just feel like I'm not holding
up my end of the deal you're gonna have
to do this on your own your feet hit
American soil and then there's a baby
yeah there's a little adjustment there
right because I'm basically a stranger
how do you reinter their lives and let
become their dad again the biggest thing
is that mom's been running the show for
nine months
you're now there
and I do look at me as soon as mom
starts you know hey you guys need to get
this done I'll pop my head around the
corner and then they kind of see me and
then they're like who dad's there now
even without children a return to
regular life is an adjustment I think I
spent two hours the first time I went
into the grocery store I walked as slow
as possible I looked at every item it's
like gym work sleep eat and that's like
the four things for nine months so when
you come back you have all these things
you can do almost to an overwhelming
extent as active-duty Marines all three
could deploy again nobody's excited to
leave their family but you also know
that if there is a job that has to be
done you kind of want to be the one to
get called up for it that's the attitude
right I mean if there's a job you guys
are ready to do it absolutely and the
next time that call comes the promise of
coming home will sustain them you just
take a step back off to the sidelines
for a second and watch everyone else
receive their family in that moment it
is like genuinely one of the happiest
times now after a short break the
journey will continue for these three
Marines captain Watkins plans to move to
California where the Marines will help
her get a degree a master's degree in
operational analysis and major Krum now
will rejoin his unit North Carolina
where he'll go back to flying major
Avera will soon get new orders that will
probably mean he and his family will
have to pack up and relocate and we'll
be checking back in to see what the next
few months will look like for all of
these three Marines we have to come up
with a whole new emotional architecture
for being back at home when when the
father said I'm a stranger that's and
like the child his kid didn't even
recognize his voice because he had heard
him on skype you know yeah and two hours
in the grocery store all the choices are
raid before you John Jim this is a great
story if this story touched you like it
touched all of us here please let us
know on Twitter you can find us at CBS
this morning
use the hashtag coming
home CTN to share your own coming home
story or to tell us about someone you
love we'll be right back